[Applaus]
ja ich bin sicher dass haben wir kommen
alle die mich sofort an alle dankeschön
bank digitale gladiator fußball spielt
man draußen auf bolzplätzen oder in
großen stadien
doch der sport hat im digitalen
zeitalter einen neuen ableger gefunden
neben anderen simulation spielen wie dr
starcraft oder league of legends wird
fifa soccer nicht nur an heimischen
konsolen gespielt sondern auch in extra
dafür eingerichteten digitalen studios
und auf großen events mit der
verbreitung und verbesserung der
internetverbindungen sind
grenzüberschreitende netzwerke von so
genannten peace portland statt
längst sind die spiele medium menschen
die sich nie in echt begegnet sind und
sich auch sonst nur digital kennen
interagieren miteinander
einer der bekanntesten deutschen
sportler ist der 17 jährige huth goethe
kindern mit der zeit habe ich mich immer
verbessert und konnte dann irgendwann
gegen meinen bruder gewinnen gegen meine
freunde gewinnen da wusste ich okay bin
eigentlich kein schlechter verstehen wie
weit er ist auch mental auch vom ehrgeiz
auch spielerisch sicherlich es da noch
luft nach oben
keine frage aber er ist aktuell auf
einem sehr guten niveau
die konkurrenz ist groß die
talentiertesten einzelspielerinnen und
einzelspieler können hohe preisgelder
gewinnen die teams sind über den ganzen
erdball verteilt dass weltweit immer
größere interesse an e sports und die
stark wachsende anzahl an zuschauern und
fans hat viele sponsoren aus virtuelle
spielfeld gelobt vier millionen menschen
in deutschland verbringen ihre zeit mit
computerspielen
für einige ist das zocken ein hobby und
für andere große vereine und verbände
haben neue abteilungen eröffnen die
wichtigsten sind schalke 04 sv werder
bremen hamburger sv
fc nürnberg pauli colette sie ist
soziologin und arbeitet seit 2010 im
büro für suchtprävention der
hamburgischen landesstelle für
suchtfragen ev computer digital games
riesengroßer bereich der mittlerweile in
der mitte der gesellschaft angekommen
ist also nicht nur kinder und
jugendliche spielen sondern auch viele
erwachsene es ist einfach eine bunte
tolle lebendige welt wo jeder jedes
mädchen wieder junge jeder mann jede
frau etwas finden kann was ihn
fasziniert seit über zehn jahren findet
die hamburg games conference statt
der treffpunkt für entwickler investoren
publisher und agenturen im fokus stehen
digitale erlösmodelle in games dann ist
er zum gamescom sitzen in hamburg sieben
der zehn größten arbeitgeber der games
branche in deutschland
hier sind sehr viele etablierte
unternehmen und insofern haben wir da
glaube ich einen ganz guten standort da
auch entsprechend weiter zu machen und
ich glaube spiele sind ein großer teil
einfach der digitalen welt und auch der
jüngeren generation also für viele sind
spiele eben das leitmedium also wenn es
darum geht wo investiere ich meine zeit
rein wird es heute bei vielen so sein
dass beispielsweise weniger tv geschaut
wird oder bücher gelesen sondern es wird
auch viel gespielt die entwickler von
spielen legen es natürlich darauf an
dass man möglichst viel zeit mit einem
spiel verbringt also das beginnt schon
damit dass immer weniger spiele
pausieren sondern einfach kontinuierlich
weiter laufen auch wenn ich vielleicht
in der schule bilden oder bei der arbeit
mit gültekin vom hsv ii sports team
tritt beim vierten sv champions cup in
paris an
hier messen sich die 32 besten fifa
spieler der welt an der playstation
mit dabei ist natürlich auch sein
trainer roberto cebit
hohmuth ist nicht der einzige spieler
aus deutschland
ramazan elmas von spvgg unterhaching
tritt zum ersten mal an der sache nie
sports team gibt es seit ende 2009 10
also ich habe erst mal als hobby
angefangen habe ab und zu gespielt mit
freunden und da habe ich gemerkt ich bin
vielleicht ein bisschen besser als
durchschnittlicher die
durchschnittlichen spieler jetzt und
dann dachte ich mir okay weil ich so was
will man denn glück habe mich dann bei
haren giesbers beworben und die haben
dann zugesagt und seitdem bin ich jetzt
service dollar
für mich ist die sports diesem namen
steckt wirklich sport hat ihn betreiben
bereich aber meint dass ich viele
komponenten gleich wie beim fußball
der ehrgeiz das training was man da
absolviert also ich finde das kann man
sehr gut miteinander vergleichen weil
ich auch selber fußballspieler und ist
betreibe ich hatte eben ihre wirklich
lust beim fußball vollgas zu geben war
das einfach körperlich viel zu
anstrengend war
und da kam auch noch die arbeit dazu die
ausbildung nicht hatte da hab ich mir
derzeit einfach nicht mehr hinbekommen
und sports resort wii sports mehrfach
jedes mal wenn ich fifa spiele spaß
macht ich glaube problematisch wird es
wenn wenning sport anerkannt wird und
dann eben auch gefördert wird als
gemeinnützig gefördert wird in
sportvereinen
weil wir auf der anderen seite natürlich
einfach hinter den spielen
publisher haben riesen anbieter von
solchen spielen die ein großes interesse
daran haben das auch schon kinder und
jugendliche relativ viel zeit vor
computerspielen verbringen also mein
ziel ist es eigentlich ein konstant
guter spieler zu werden also ich hatte
jetzt im vergangenen monat ein sehr
gutes turnier und dass ich so eine
leistung auch beibehalten konnten die
trainer robert seeber sagt übermut die
dass er sehr ehrgeizig ist und sich
besonders gut auf seine ziele
fokussieren kann
gamer wie er trainieren bis zu zehn
stunden täglich
das wird er hat ganz viel diskutiert
wenn man von beim sport wirklich vom
klassischen spot sprechen kann und dann
gibt es ja noch keine endgültige
entscheiden jetzt bezieht auf grafik
es ist heute sicherlich schon möglich
dass man sich ein computerspiel anguckt
in dem fußball gespielt wird und auf den
ersten blick kann als nicht
unterscheiden von einer tv-übertragung
also da glaube ich ist schon diese
vermischung da es ist real einfach
deswegen weil wir hier in paris sind das
ist eines der größten turniere der welt
und es werden uns über hunderttausend
leute weltweit zu schauen die leute
werden nicht nur das spiel sehen was
gespielt wird sondern sie sehen auch die
gesichter der spieler die vor dem
bildschirm sitzen das heißt es ist es
ist am ende des tages ist es wie der
echte fußball du siehst spieler die ein
spiel spielen du guckst ihnen dabei zu
es ist komplett real
der größte unterschied ist einfach dass
die jungs sich auf dem platz bewegen
dass sie sich körperlich betätigen und
dass man bei der konsole eben sich nicht
körperlich betätigt sondern nur das
gehirn sehr angestrengt wird die jungs
die hier sitzen die sie laufen jetzt
keine zwölf kilometer in 90 minuten
es ist es ist natürlich schon was
anderes aber am ende des tages ist
beides ja eine eine form von fußball
ich glaube erwachsene menschen ältere
menschen machen wir noch einen klaren
unterschied zwischen der realen welt und
der digitalen welt
ich glaube je jünger die menschen sind
also babys heutzutage wachsen in
digitalisierten lebenswelten auf und
wenn ich mit jugendlichen sprechen dann
habe ich nicht das gefühl dass die noch
so stark unterscheiden zwischen analog
und digital ich glaube das vermischt
sich heutzutage immer mehr haben für
mich ist eigentlich alles real also auch
wenn ich das spiel spielen hier auch in
der realen welt natürlich aber es halt
so wenn ich dann im spiel bin dann ist
er voller fokus natürlich auf dem spiel
und da ist man halt so und ohne dass man
nicht außenwelt fast gar nicht mehr
mitbekommt dass man wirklich fast schon
gefangen in dem spiel das find ich das
schon auch dass man auch in der
virtuellen welt ist also diejenigen die
lieber in der virtuellen welt bleiben
wollen im spiel bleiben wollen und nicht
mehr in der realen welt sein weil die
erleben dort vielmehr belohnung und
bestätigung als
real werde die fühlen sich sicherer im
computerspiel ich habe gemerkt dass ich
zwar auch du bist talent habe und ich
bin jetzt auch nicht alle sehr niedrig
aber ich meine profi fußball reicht es
dato noch nicht also da habe ich gesehen
dass zum beispiel jetzt dadurch hat mich
entschieden mehr auf den sport zu
fokussieren weil ich sehe dass ich dort
mehr talent habe und mein potenzial
auszuschöpfen das auch mal irgendwann
beruflich zu machen ich denke wenn ich
gleich palent hätte dann würde ich auf
jeden fall fußball bevorzugen also wie
ein fluss fall also am ende des tages
auf unser kerngeschäft fußball und der
export ist eine ergänzung zu unserem
kerngeschäft deswegen spezialisieren wir
uns aktuell auch nur auf eine
fußballsimulation und das wird von den
fans sehr gut angenommen weil sie
natürlich auch direkt die parallele
erkannt haben zu zum echten rasensport
zu der bundesliga und zur ersten zweiten
bundesliga die debatte um den e sport
dreht sich indessen weiter der deutsche
olympische sportbund hat bisher
computerspiele nicht als sport definiert
2017 haben die spd cdu und csu in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag in aussicht gestellt
den sport vollständig als eigene
sportart mit vereins und verbands recht
anzuerkennen
denn zitat es werden wichtige
fähigkeiten geschult nicht nur in der
digitalen welt von bedeutung sind und
training und sport strukturen erfordert